in the previous episode salarino basa Oh
worry about Ohio [ __ ] Oh
today's the day our dream machine father
rolls off the drawing board and on to
the stage of motor well you didn't tell
your mom about it did ya
perfect then tonight's the night yeah
it's all what yeah [ __ ] yeah
damn it
Arriba you can idea hora sequani a dude
she teleported away
Oh Toby you're sick I was gone too soon
she'll what anybody's after all right
hatred movies Oh Reba look uh you could
ease up there Arriba that's not Arriba
closer or mine
poor boy nice job mean that though I'm
not gonna cook yeah I will mom I uh-huh
she dying
no no no no no no close huh Gaza yeah
yeah
one day while they are the one to slay
wahdahu la Morita miss gotto Jesus so
they were supposed to kill the child and
Angela
Yaga need an Omaha
it's in Oconee discussion not yeah dot
economy no kuni tomita Bakari return so
do whatever I also reading this paper
you're so evil I hate you don't you
let's do it
need to look guilty when she has a
galaxy in her cape that's [ __ ]
bad-ass I want that all right
holy [ __ ] this is quite interesting it's
a lot of Anamika Odaiba must've cost a
fortune
good it's like cocoa Neolithic era Otto
day what a day
poor Oliver man poor guy
my god I can't it's fat as [ __ ]
well what do you think oh yeah oh yeah
Erica go ha ha hey Carlotta yo Cal I saw
Dannette mommy camasta don't I own my
legs real again yeah oh that's the thing
we saw her in the beginning is that
thing gonna come alive
it's so awesome Kassem a joke ROC go
Tony kiddo
Sammy's connector economy no water what
in it cuz I so came it's cotton all that
attention
Tony Bhavan s yo kita kita Oh Jack what
is the bounding I need
cuz um
- laughs what
okay 100 : I got Gallo say she'sa cuz
I'm on a country you know what a fairy
you look beautiful oh I'm dosa
dr. umma miso miso miso miso nah no my
Huachuca this way
Nick corner not ID number under me can I
just get it to nabela yo listen up
Mina hey crying make your bread become
born or whatever the [ __ ] Oh simmer
horsey honk the contact okay
son I know since me son check it out Oh
soon as you can address it to me not
good game huh hey pop ha how dare you
ate my pie you betcha
[ __ ] Anna no deals
an asteroid so I don't want see you when
I tape mmm okay given you're gonna take
our yacht you will consecrate Akkadian I
say cranial or Eduardo Chitina Yokosuka
gari huh
all right lemme go oh yeah no sekai
ninokuni Chiana eno-kun yet so solo
ninokuni no taiyou say no or ESO moverá
nom de Cuyo tato you Hodag Dana Thomas
Egan we haveá--
Katie Correa floor again yeah me no mado
see Tom OTT abscessed oh no kokoro see
heist a new Crimea are a social media Oh
Sofia honey you take another this
Moondoggie Cassio radon Amir Agha or any
captain
Yami no ma hoga to get a non totaku como
soy tu CC so Mia Taha stoah meet again I
don't you go home on e raha Oh Maya
korekara Orono second eno-kun in each
day yami no mado seotaiji stay Morocco
yeah that's where I would be right
look at that pink cap in the McNamara
dies even take a loot a or a gossip or
Oh Susanna
hey hey gah am I gonna die zero for the
feudal a QC should all what your little
secret scooty taki Moscow do I get to
choose yes yes yes yes what what what
what's wrong with you what do you didn't
whooping your destroyer
you killed it who living as a pseudonym
why honey my saga video Gary by eurocom
damn so your papaya papaya uncle Isaac
what - I'm sorry dope or Jahangir
why not come on Dom deal
now okay don't even look on Oh sassy
Marissa to me
yeah gotta make the win oh why is he so
mean to him
show some compassion damn it doridori
Oh kurama's allah whom the golden
'golden tryna do Stano what why he's
shuffling what about my don't [ __ ]
spiritum sinful hey no no it's me papa
to kick him a scar Oh golly yes kono
sekai Tonino kini restore eat oh no
Thomas Lowe Samaha uno second inning
gave a Nino creamy Mo's son died sir una
caja Co motrin wha meet amay mone T's
mommy v/o Marrero Oconto Tomasi okay
usted no ah ninokuni no Kenza re
shiozawa to you again aah aah
Kenji Osama demo square dou T dou Y koto
Odysseus ami no mado giovanna eskas
llamo check our agnya Bray yeah c-note a
magneto e humid air dhoti guardo mu C
Soria entre rejas day Sara mom Anna
chose de cámara de Tomasino slavery
Akita yeah see no tama Cara Alicia Samos
Cuba monochromatic adair ok Muslim Punto
Havana in Cairo so inclusive are you
alright oh I can do da en de Rivoli nan
desuka Sangha so no koto Esther oh no no
Tony in Giovanni said Sandy's oh oh
es muy era su Riviera ninokuni rio-são
or decay an i or a gal go korea i de
arriba naka Makara no okay to t toga
my panda ute pasión en su de y ni de una
sólo yo satan a [ __ ] osika any nadrazi
or a Stoughton yabo no koto sagres atari
sultan layer Aaronovitch as I do Nesta
what I'm do it Cleo yeah no Kuni Niko
aha
yay hasta la donna de Hierro Marrero
soryo ninokuni Ordinariate ananda
so traverse iguazu yeah so so d gujja me
no can eat a toy at econo
she's like hmm yo Sita Marzu ma who Anna
Neagle mythical Tomasi okay Hawk Street
oh ho no yay no econo tonica's Odyssey
yeah no no no no Tony Kaku Don Lollo
nakaya's like dick okay well I guess
we're going to luck in our fireplace
hey um actually I do not start to fit oh
it's lucky out the fireplace man
downstairs in the flippin bleb mm you
even left me dead yeah okay so I need to
go downstairs cool
I can do that I love the [ __ ] sound
that comes when he's following me hi oi
oi stop following me it's a living room
right hey we are quite splendid lovely
lovely weather why would they be a
lunatic alone in an economy
say ah hoo hooey ah muy teri Okita
yeah seem polite magic to mastaba Dondo
no he nincada - non easy no ma hoon
discarnate soon on Oh buddy huh you got
it
you get that book if you buy the wizard
edition what I got mejor Nachum yeah say
kakuni ah my whole scene on show magic
come us time magic camasta mushy sniffs
nah cool we got a wizard back now listen
up I'm gonna teach you wanted in the
wisdom compute if you want to have a
read of it press square triangle to open
the main menu you should see down at the
bottom right over there then you just
need to choose it with X and you can
leave through the wizard companion to
your hearts it's not a misspelling
you are where your uh your your heart's
content
silly affiliations can't even spell
take a minute or two to have a skin love
a few pay I shouldn't say anything
all right you look like a Smollett what
thank you
yes uh nice some gum I'm gonna show you
get into it I almost forgot the first
thing you have to do when you get you uh
am I [ __ ] drunk or something since am
I missing something here only with his
companion is to make a pledge you need
to vow that you'll do all you can do to
be a worthy to be were there being a way
that don't lets a flap a [ __ ] word
it's not hard all you have to do is
write your name in the book widow okay
honest hard you don't even have to write
Oliver if you don't want you can write
bunting cry-baby or whatever you like
the important thing is that you mean it
go on scribble your name I can write
whatever as long as I mean it huh
interesting
I'm just kidding I'm just [ __ ] with
your bra's let's go with let's go with
kids all caps like that I'm [ __ ]
happy as hell
man I bet Colby nomadic now what's up
what's the good look tidy right Kosuke
yeah totally when Louis Donna
Maho nutria anger my horse Konya chilly
creatures kill
ah silly me I don't have one are you men
dog scigirls cotton aha so Tony ma who
knows SRC play yeah so Tony Manero
monkey doh
Eric you so miso miso mukla or e ba
message ni kimeta tu dinero
oh my I miss with mom it's so mean why
would he be show me writer time to find
ourselves our self ours who did the [ __ ]
Emmet however you mean there's one
hidden somewhere around here like the
spell book ha whatever you're having a
laugh if you think I'm going to make it
that easy money what do you think I am
made of Wizarding equipment no this
one's gonna be a little more difficult
but our journey over to my boys is a
hunt for the soul snare among other
things why don't you treat this as a
warm-up knees to rag hunt before the
wild goose chase if you will the huh
okay I guess okay I'm lying the thing is
I never brought brought a wand with me I
shed I mean look at me the prize of my
love ability is as small as a statue
isn't it small statutes their stature
ain't it
okay I only managed to carry that
flipping book my Mun if you like it's
supposed to be Jamaican or some [ __ ]
anymore not being crushed
so even Ferriss headlines huh of course
they do
as parents are incorrigible liar anyway
no point crying of the spell make let's
find our self or substitute show me a
substitute how can there be a substitute
for a magic wand
well I've you can find something brown
and sticky like a that sound
really
anyway like maybe a stick we might just
be able to muddle after I haven't seen
any okay you're sure a stick will work
you think I'm sending you up the garden
path of dumping fine I'll give you a
hand follow me bunting all right we're
following him I wonder if anyone else
can see him hey can you see this what do
you think all of the day looks a little
bit now like we know to leave imagine
things far there isn't so much Twiggy
attached punished yes ma'am thank you
for doing that
oh they don't need to fight video
mouthing mm-hmm why is she still
cleaning then find a stick all right
let's find a stick what's up what are
you looking at
don't tell me you're thinking of using
your lamb pose as a flippin wrong well
you can cut that out for a start is way
to flippin begging you just sticker some
like that name why don't we go and have
a look over there okay that girl only to
clean all the stick so we can use her
she's using a pen car my god I want to
talk to these people what's up the
Dalton motorway are all fine I'm sensing
which means you'll grow into a fine of
senescence and your mother can be sure
of that
however she is now a fetch mention my
mama this is one proper tidying mode
right might get myself want to be I'm
sorry Niles rather a tie with it doing
anything one like over by Harry then
let's go and look over the other side
shall we okay
oh and when you find something don't
forget to pop it in your bag for
safekeeping I was gonna tell him how to
use the bag now
I don't need this [ __ ] cut in my bag
sure put in my back it's a bottomless
bag I also didn't did I also want to
have a bottom bottomless bottomless
something oh there's a star over here
let's check over here
no one can see drifty but me that's kind
of cool I guess alright right over here
what do we got
I am [ __ ] freezing today it's really
[ __ ] cold
you think Italy would be hot but no no
it's nowt sigh it's no yes there's
nothing around there that looks like a
while it's already night we walked 5
meters
they're not wrong bunting all right well
we baited slit split up then broaden the
search like I'll go and take another
quick look around your house you stay by
here and head up the outside search ok
ok ok
brown and sticky brown and sticky oh
yeah
it's not longer probably what's that
freaky teleporting uh oh it's yeah [ __ ]
that [ __ ] she can teleport teach me how
to a mean teleport teach me what sass me
kono mama at Iona at IO na kimi o dost a
boku no koto stare no Arriba Khun na
mama no puto
maurella cumin
sonna dose take me go Amano
ah mater Kimi token ichigo's teleporting
again dokoni tano Oh Yuri mom story
Durrani sinner uh Shizuka Medina gonna
cheat ah ah nah he got shaky no no no ko
Bocconi need Omaha Nishioka text and oh
yeah you see no no wanna toss can you
see aa sigatoka DN son and I Oh Yamazaki
cert the key chatter ah Sione stoughton
feet amigo oh hi Dozo walk in Maputo no
mother Kong Kong
moto yo soy una hamas to soy - Arlo car
see aha
namu Amida Yakko Toa miss granny our
Moon Danann toka kudo asuka-dono pay
katisa moon adidas Tiana oh hi I know
Bogota by Sunni Korra goats Tito
hmm total body you oh do be clear
mama mama hey ma ma ho no sir Orihime
Artem IVA tada noche de groan ah
cou many no Kuni no Musa I want our
Grega ninokuni let's karate Ramos nan de
de Tolosa de fondos kuroi sena tornado
bra ido imagine obscene ox garbage
Accord a severe Yatta Yatta
come on sugar daddy sorry Akane Nevada
nice carbonara OS castara a no koga boku
ni Todoke take retinal camo probably I
mean it was right there word lovely
I bet obtain enough yeah my horse called
Bachna now we need to place the cast our
state Omaha taking of a hero ie buzzing
Who I am
say my daughter took the Haggadah
critical care got on a bit sandy
how could you cannot date on 9 July da
cunha blog on ma who was Susie know my
horse Caldecott's Lenny pesto nacho
tidier on akane tsunemori tina key we
are a cure oh we do yeah ah ha he leave
us alone nice to get Lucario he leave us
all he really but okay we'll go into the
town square
party well so no one is worried about a
boy who runs off in the middle of the
night and his mom just passed away no no
one gives a [ __ ]
apparently but this is a good Town so
you know nothing bad
look at that cow look at that I just
love to walk after dark are you out
walking to give me that dog dog
give me that dog what happens if I get
run over by a car that was close keep
going what about drippy can drippy get
run over by car
my car's just chilling night this is not
GTA pills I'm at high done hello young
Oliver I added for the sound scratch yep
I won't know later this it can't be that
late because you did whoa credit guru
the who Tony Aaron dies oh yeah goodsoon
on ingonyama homie I'm sorry ma
kids okay hmm normal people can't see
the madding alright well I guess he's
[ __ ] our first spell it's an alum it's
a gateway hmm
yes a bank we get to you spell
you get a little juice yeah
oh I think that one
it's the Omega weather when I click with
that
I want to do that I want to do that
what
ah I like the dark and say oh my god
every time my dog barks I mean what is
it really
when I grab miss Oakley whoa Oh anybody
I already bah ha ha ha
this one is mama
you
Oh
we're going to ninokuni why maybe that
means another world I press tell me
which favorite movie from Studio Ghibli
is your favorite and I'll see you
tomorrow
like favorite enjoyed subscribe to
become a better day and I'll see you
next episode I mean come on